you do so much great improv on Curb Your
Enthusiasm with Larry David and you have
actually because you improvise together
you've taught him some phrases that he
didn't know oh you're real is that right
oh yeah good mad ass is one over the
white Jewish guys know about getting
that ass
well that one you can kind of figure out
what it means you know it's not like it
no no apparently not
I promise you hell what the hell getting
that ass was huh love someone kissing
your ass you don't know what the hell
getting that ass are you saying getting
that ass are getting in that ass good
another that dat get in that ass dad ass
dad adds that afton that ass okay what
does that mean that means you're getting
someone's ass you understand verbally
it's like a verbal ass woman see oh
means like you you give him a tongue
lashing is that with a verbal ass
whuppin it's called getting to that ass
cuz that can mean other things to be I
look good I thought it would meant
you're sort of you know on the hunt for
sexual conquest I'm getting that ass
very powerful no one does that
oh boy
oh that s to defend yourself as a man
Oh people don't know where it all came
from know what getting a guess as it
came from no it came from Gulliver's
Travels sure of course
sure yeah he's the giant and then
there's the tiny little people the
Lilliputians you a giant awkward man
[Applause]
with you on this one yeah tell the story
I'll tell the story you pertain you're
Gulliver okay get to where Sir
[Applause]
workshopping know what do i doing now
everything I tell you to do you do okay
so Gulliver kullaberg right
he wandered his way into Lilliput right
Wanda Wanda OS Wanda got a little tired
the man got a loti sure he he he had to
rest he lay down he laid down the rest
Oh Oh lay down the rest oh and while he
was sleeping the little uns came over
there and cut his damn throat it cut has
got them throw it cut it got them throw
right right right and then it cut his
throat and then they turned his ass over
I turn them over we turn it over turn
them on
turned his ass over to turn his ass down
lay down
I got a cut ass throat and while he was
why he was there
right his throat was cut this man was
dead I killed this man right or and why
he was sleeping right there dug in his
ass that dogs a tunnel into his head the
tunnel tore it in two colors ass but for
what for when burned and it was caught
gulliver's tunnel okay
okay now all these all these little
people would go into his ass yeah but it
would hang out in his ass okay right
they will hang out in his ass they they
started to develop in his ass right go
bowling alleys courts laser tag place
right even little pooches love laser tag
they playing all in his ass right
Oh in the man's ass right yeah they're
moving all around in there yeah okay
just going on in there yeah that's
laughing goings over there so the bottom
line is you always get in someone's ass
before they get in yours
that's the bottom line right
see that was the most beautiful
children's story I think I've ever heard
good work kids coming home from
Halloween they turn on Conan and they
hear this wonderful story about the
Lille appeal does it's on the pin the
pictures for you make it clear
yeah pretty than else get in that ass
all right
you